and lisa and andy which side are you on
i'm on the side of the people who are
building and creating and driving this
country whether they work on the
railways or they're trying to use the
railways to get to work of course we
don't want strikes to have to go ahead
this week i live in the north of england
we've had 10 years of underfunding bad
management and broken promises on the
railways and we know what it means when
the railways grind to a halt but that's
why the government has got to get round
the table with the cleaners and the
ticket office staff and the station
workers to resolve this because they're
the only people who can only a few years
ago grant chaps was calling them true
heroes now he's refusing to meet them
the government government hasn't lifted
a finger since march to engage in those
talks and during the pandemic they took
the right to negotiate back from the
train operating companies so they're the
only people who can resolve this and yet
they're not prepared to do it the
biggest problem that this country has is
not militant workers it's a militant
government
you say that you don't want to see the
strikes um happen but of course you know
anyone would say that you know the rmt
would say that the government would say
that it's effectively a bit kind of
meaningless and westrooting has said
previously that if he was a member of
the rmt then he would vote for
industrial action would you
well i would i i'm not a member of the
rmt what i am is a member of parliament
aspiring to form the next government and
i can tell you what we would do in
government we would get around the table
with the
workers that grant chaps was calling
true heroes only a couple of years ago
and listen seriously to their concerns
it's not payroll they want a pay rise of
11 percent
would you agree to that what is
happening on the railways and that is
exactly what the welsh government did
that the reason that you haven't got
strikes in wales and you have got
strikes in england is because in wales
you've got a labour government and in
england you've got a tory government
it's not about whether workers go on
strike it's about the fact that we've
got a government that is currently on
strike and not doing its job
and it's pretty clear that you obviously
want the government to get around the
table and and you want you see
negotiation as the way forward but i'm
just trying to kind of get to grips with
in the current situation
where your sympathies effectively are
you know mick lynn she will be talking
to in a moment he previously told me
that kirsten hasn't made it clear that
he's on the side of the workers if we
just get this bland democratic party
sitting in the center of politics taking
their instructions off the daily mail to
some extent not getting behind workers
struggles you have to ask yourself why
should they call themselves the labour
party what do you say to that
well what i'd say to that is that i want
a government that actually delivers for
all of its working people these are the
people who built this country who kept
us going during the pandemic whether
they work in the private sector and are
trying to get to work on the railways or
work in the public sector trying to help
people get to work on the railways i
want a government that delivers and that
is what labour stands for this
government stands against all of those
people only this weekend they were
briefing out to the media that they'd
had a good week a wedge week they were
calling it because presumably they've
been able to pick worker against worker
which is how they plan to maintain
themselves in power i'm calling it out
because grant chaps has got some brass
neck to come on your program when this
government is presiding over
soaring inflation rates the highest in
30 years and has no plan to tackle the
cost of living they've dragged their
feet on it for months and they've got no
plan to get growth back into the economy
this is a government that in 2019
came to power on a promise to level up
and instead what they've presided over
is absolute chaos chaos at the ports
chaos on the railways chaos at airports
chaos everywhere you go and that is
because this is a government that is not
doing its job
uh talking to grant shops earlier into
specifically talking about the strike
says still you know the rmt want pay
risers to keep place with uh inflation
and for many people who
pay is not going to be rising like
anything like that that's going to seem
like a pretty tall order he also made
the point about the amount of money that
taxpayers are currently pouring into the
railways at four fifths of the 21
billion cost of britain's railways works
out about 600 pounds per household is it
not right that there are efficiency
savings that have to be made on the
railways as effectively fewer people use
them
well the efficiency savings that
are being driven largely actually by
frontline staff who can see where
there's waste and are trying to take
action to deal with it i don't think
it's an efficiency saving though to say
you want to take a guard off a train i'm
not sure when grunt shops last got on a
train but the railways are fast becoming
no-go areas for many many people people
with disabilities
older people people in
women particularly traveling late at
night you know in the north of england
we remember this well we had
the ira bombs in manchester and
warrington
when i was growing up we had we've had a
terrorist attack at the manchester arena
in the face of all of that the
government should not be calling it
efficiency savings to take skilled
experienced staff off the railways who
helped to keep us safe that is why his
interview with you sophie was so utterly
disingenuous because what he really
knows is that the repeated amount of
cuts that he's trying to make to the
railways don't just harm the people who
work on them they harm the traveling
public as well
okay
now kirsten has submitted his
questionnaire to durham police um so if
he's found guilty of covert rule
breaches we know that he said
that he will uh resign
according to the sunday times he's been
doing a bit of succession planning just
in case that happens not assuming that
it's going to happen but just in case
apparently telling friends i will not
let this party become a basket case
again now the times reports it's
understood that he has since met a
number of members of his shadow cabinet
with leadership ambitions and has urged
them to put campaign teams in place
has he spoken to you
there's absolute nonsense no he hasn't
and i've spoken to him twice in the last
couple of days about how we persuade
this government to lift a finger to
avert a crisis on the railways are you a
bit worried he's been talking to where
streeting and not your local government
funding
sorry
again are you a bit worried he's been
talking to west routing and not you
well no i'm not worried that he's been
talking to anybody about succession
planning because i know that he's been
talking to all of us about how we rid
this country of a government that has
held us back for the last 12 years and
finally start to deliver for working
people that is the conversation that
we're having in the labour party at the
moment our eyes are not on the labour
party for too long we spent time
debating the labour party we care about
the country that's what we're in
politics for and that's what we're
discussing
there are you say that you know we're
all discussing about politics but there
is obviously um
discussions going on in shadow cabinet
that perhaps a little bit less favorable
um lots of reports that members of the
cheddar cabinet have been telling
kirsten would stop being so boring
leaking stories to the media he
apparently addressed it in shadow
cabinet
and effectively told them to stop
what is going on is that true
no we're completely focused on what is
happening in the country at the moment
because we live in it and we couldn't
care more about the fact that at the
moment you've got a lot of people not
just some people now but most people who
really can't make ends meet i can't
remember a time when people worked this
hard and then got home at the end of the
week or the month and found that they
couldn't keep their heads above water
the soaring inflation rates aren't just
causing problems for families they're
causing problems for businesses as well
and every bit of our energy is going
into not just being an opposition to
this appalling government but to being a
genuine alternative so that come the
next general election we can finally
move forwards as a country and start to
get money back into communities good
jobs back into communities money back
into people's pockets and get this
country working again
if every bit of your energy is focused
on that on becoming the alternative to
the government why haven't you got more
eye-catching policies is the problem not
that kierstan was too boring but that
your policies are a bit too boring
well i'm standing here in warwick today
at the labour local government
conference where keira and i are setting
out plans to smash up a central century
of centralization and to get power back
into local hands and into communities
where it belongs we've done it before in
government through the regional
development agencies we were able to
bring advanced manufacturing jobs to
rotherham we were able to bring wind
energy jobs to grimsby now there are
kids in grimsby who are powering the
world from the grimsby docks getting
money back into people's pockets and
money back into the local community
that's what we're going to do again it
is bold it is ambitious but it's also
not any more ambitious than people in
this country are for themselves their
families their lives and their
communities and they deserve a
government that will meet that level of
ambition this one's not going to do it
so we are